The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today,
what we're going
to do is, first, introduce
this idea of oscillations.
It might be useful.
A fair amount of the day will
be spent discussing this paper
by Michael Elowitz
and Stan Leibler
that you read over the last few
days, which was the first, kind
of, experimental
demonstration that you
could take these
random components,
put them together, and generate
oscillatory gene networks.
And finally, it's
likely we're going
to run out of time around here.
But if we have time, we'll talk
about other oscillator designs.
In particular, these
relaxation oscillators
that are both
robust and tunable.
It's likely we're going to
discuss this on Tuesday.
All right, so I want to
start by just thinking
about other oscillator designs.
But before we get
into that, it's
worth just asking a question.
Why is it that we might want
to design an oscillator?
What do we like
about oscillations?
Does anybody like oscillations?
And if so, why?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You can make clocks.
And clocks are really--
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
Yes, all right.
So two part answer.
You can make clocks.
And clocks are useful.
All right.
OK, so this is a fine statement.
So oscillators are, kind of,
the basis for time keeping.
And indeed, classic ideas of
clocks, like a pendulum clock.
The idea is that
you have this thing.
It's going back and forth.
And each time that
it goes, it let
allows some winding
mechanism to move.
And that's what
the clock is based.
And even modern clocks
are based on some sort
of oscillatory dynamic.
It might be a very
high frequency.
But in any case, the
basic idea of oscillations
as a mechanism for time keeping
is why we really care about it.
Of course, just from a
dynamical systems perspective,
we also like oscillations
because they're
interesting from a
dynamical standpoint.
And therefore, we'd
like to know how
we might be able to make them.
Can anybody offer an example
of an oscillator in a G network
in real life?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Circadian.
PROFESSOR: The
circadian oscillator.
That's right.
So the idea there
is that there's
a G network within
many organizations
that actually keeps
track of the daily cycle
and, indeed, is entrained
by the daily cycle.
So of course, the
day, night cycle.
That's an oscillator.
It's on its own.
And it goes without us, as well.
But it's often
useful for organisms
to be able to keep track of
where in the course the day
it might be.
And the amount of light
that the organism is getting
at this particular
moment might not
be a faithful indicator
of how much light there
will be available in an
hour because it could just
be that there's a cloud
crossing in front of the sun.
And you don't want--
as an organism--
to think that it's night.
And then, you shut
down all that machinery
because, after
that cloud passes,
you want to be able
to get going again.
So it's often useful
for an organism
to know where in the morning,
night, evening cycle one is.
And we will not be talking
too much about the circadian
oscillators in this class.
Although, I would say to
the degree of your interest
in oscillations, I
strongly encourage
you to look up that literature
because it's really beautiful.
In particular, in some
of these oscillators,
it's been demonstrating you can
get the oscillations in vitro.
I.e, outside of the cell.
Even in the absence of any
gene expression, in some cases,
you can still get oscillations
of just those protein
components in a test tube.
This was quite a
shocking discovery
when it was first published.
But we want to start out
with some simpler ones.
In particular, I want
to start by thinking
about auto repression.
So if you have an auto
regulatory loop where
some gene is repressing
itself, the question
is does this thing oscillate.
And indeed, it's
reasonable that it
might because we can
construct a verbal argument.
Starts out high.
Then, it should
repress itself so you
get less new x being made.
So the concentration falls.
So maybe I'll give you
a plot to add to it.
Concentration of x is
a function of time.
You can imagine just
starting somewhere high.
That means it's a
repressing expression.
So it's going to fall.
But then, once it falls too
much, then all of a sudden,
OK, well we're not
repressing ourselves anymore.
So maybe then we
get more expression.
More of this x is being made.
So it should come back up.
And then, now we're
back where we started.
So this is a totally
reasonable statement.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well I don't know.
I mean, I didn't introduce
any damping in here.
The amplitude is
the same everywhere.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
that you could actually
have something--
PROFESSOR: Well I guess what
I'm really trying to say
is that just because you can
construct a verbal argument
that something happens does not
mean that a particular equation
is going to do that.
Part of the value
of equations is
that they force you to
be explicit about all
the assumptions
that you're making.
And then what you're
going to do is
you're going to ask,
well, a given equation is
a mathematical manifestation of
the assumptions you're making.
And then, you're going to
ask does that oscillate.
Yes/no?
And then you're going
to say, OK, well
what would we need
to change in order
to introduce oscillations?
And I'll just-- OK.
So this is definitely
an oscillation.
The question is, should
you find this argument
I just gave you convincing?
And what I'm, I guess, about
to say is that you shouldn't.
But then, we need to be clear
about what's going on and why.
And just because you can make
a verbal argument for something
doesn't mean that
it actually exist.
I mean, that's a guide
to how you might want
to formalize your thinking.
And in particular,
the simplest way
to think about oscillations
that might be induced
in this situation would
be to just say, all right,
well the simplest model
we have for an auto
regulatory loop that's
negative is we say,
OK, well there's some alpha
1 plus protein and minus p.
So this is, kind of,
the simplest equation
you can write that captures
this idea that this protein
p is negatively regulating
itself in a cooperative fashion
maybe.
Now it's already in a
non-dimensionalize version.
Right?
And what you can see is
that, within this realm,
there are only two things
that can possibly be changing.
There's how cooperative
that repression
is-- n-- and then, the
strength of the expression
in the absence of repression.
And as we discussed
on Tuesday, alpha
is capturing all these
dynamics of the actual strength
of expression together with
the lifetime of the protein
together with the binding.
You know, the
binding affinity k.
So all those things get wrapped
up in this a or alpha rather.
All right, so this is,
indeed, the simplest model
you can write down to
describe such a negative auto
regulatory loop.
Now the question is now
that we've done this,
we want to know does
this thing oscillate.
And even without
analyzing this equation,
there's something that's very
strong, which you can say.
So in theory we're going to ask
is it possible for this thing
to oscillate.
All right.
Possible.
Your oscillations, we'll
say oscillations possible.
And this time, referring
to mathematically possible.
So maybe this thing
does oscillate.
Maybe it doesn't.
But in particular,
without analyzing it,
is there anything that you
can say without analyzing it?
We're just going to
say is it possible.
Yes or no?
If you say no, you
have to be prepared
to give an argument for
why this thing is not
allowed to oscillate.
I'm talking about this equation.
Do you don't you
understand the question
that I'm trying to ask?
And we haven't analyzed
this thing yet.
But the question is,
even before analyzing it,
can we say anything about
whether it's mathematically
allowed to oscillate?
I'll give you 10 seconds
to think about it.
And if you say no, you
get to tell me why.
All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
All right, so we got a
smattering of things.
So I think this is not,
obviously, a priori.
But it turns out that
it's not actually.
It's just mathematically
impossible for this hing
to oscillate.
And can somebody say
why that might be?
AUDIENCE: Because it
might be you could only
have one value of p dot?
PROFESSOR: Perfect OK.
So for a given
value of p, there's
only some value of p
dot that you can have.
And in a particular-- so p here
is like a concentration of x.
So I'm going to pick some
value, randomly, here of p.
And what you're
pointing out is this
is a differential
equation in which
if you give me or I give you
the p, you can give me p dot.
And there's a single
value p dot for each p.
And in this oscillatory
scheme, is that statement true?
No.
What you can see is
that, over here, this is
x slash p concentration of x.
We're using p here because
we're about to start
talking about mRNA So I want to
keep the notation consistent.
What you see is that the
derivative here is negative.
The derivative here is positive.
Negative, positive.
So any oscillation that you're
going to be able to imagine
is going to have multiple
values for the derivative
as a function of that
value just because you
have to come back and forth.
You have to cross that
point multiple times.
So what this is saying is that
since this is a differential
equation-- and it's
actually important
that it's a differential
equation rather
than a difference equation
where you have discrete values.
But given that this is a
differential equation where
time is taking little,
little, little steps
and you have a single variable,
it just can't oscillate.
So for example, if you're
talking about the oscillations
the harmonic oscillator
the important thing there
is a you have both the
position in the velocity
see these two dynamical
variables that are interacting
in some way because you have
momentum, in that case, that
allows for the oscillations in
the case of a mass on a spring,
for example.
Question.
AUDIENCE: I'm still
not understanding.
So the value of p
can not oscillate?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we're saying is that, right,
p simply cannot oscillate
in this situation where we
have a differential equation
describing p with-- if we just
have p dot as a function of p
and we don't have
a second order.
A p double dot, for example.
So if we just have a single
derivative with respect to time
and some function of p
over here, what that means
is that, if p is specified,
then p dot is specified.
And that's inconsistent
with any sort of oscillation
because any oscillation's going
to require that, at this is
given value of p-- this
concentration of p--
in this case, the
concentration's going down.
Here, it's going up.
So here, this is--
from that standpoint--
a multi valued function.
OK?
And other questions
about this statement?
Even if I just written down some
other function of p over here,
this statement
would still be true.
And it's valuable to be able to
have some intuition about what
are the essential ingredients
to get this sort of oscillation.
And for simple harmonic
motion, right there we
have the second derivative,
first derivative,
and that's what allows
oscillations there.
OK, so we can, maybe, write
down a more complicated model
of a negative auto regulation.
And then, try to
ask the same thing.
Might this new model oscillate?
And this looks a little
bit more complicated.
But we just have to be
a little bit careful.
All right, so this is, again,
negative auto-regulation.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to explicitly think about the
concentration of the mRNA.
OK.
And that's just because when a
gene is initially transcribed,
it first makes mRNA.
And then, the mRNA is
translated into protein.
Right?
So what we can do
is we can write down
something that looks like this.
M dot derivative of m
with respect to time.
It's going to be--
all right, so this
is the concentration of mRNA.
And p is the
concentration of protein.
OK?
All right, and
what you can see is
that the protein
is now repressing
expression of the mRNA.
mRNA is being degraded.
But then, down here, this
is a little bit funny.
But what you can see is
that, if you have more mRNA,
then that's going to lead to
the production of protein.
Yet, we also have a degradation
term for the protein.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why are we
multiplying the degradation
rate of the protein
times some beta, as well?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
OK, you're wondering why
we've pulled out this beta.
In particular-- right.
OK, perfect.
OK, yeah.
This is very important.
And actually, this
gets in-- once again--
to this question of these
non-dimensional versions
of equations.
Mathematically, simple.
Biologically, very complicated.
Well, first of all, what is that
we've used as our unit of time
in these equations?
AUDIENCE: The life of mRNA.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's based on the
lifetime of the mRNA
because we can see
that there's nothing
sitting in front of this m.
And if we want to, then,
allow for a difference
in the lifetime
mRNA and protein,
then we have to introduce
some other thing, which
we're calling beta.
So beta is the ratio of--
well which one's more stable?
mRNA or protein,
often, typically?
AUDIENCE: Protein.
PROFESSOR: Proteins are,
typically, more stable.
So does that mean
that beta should
be larger or smaller than 1?
OK, I'm going to let you
guys think about this just
make sure we're all--
OK, so the question
is beta, A, greater than 1?
Typically, much greater.
Or is it, B, much less than
1, given what we just said?
All right, you think
about it for 10 seconds.
All right.
Are you ready?
Three, two, one.
All right, so most
people are saying B.
So indeed, beta should
be much less than 1.
And that's because beta is
the ratio of the lifetime.
So you can see, if
beta gets larger,
that increases the degradation
rate of the protein.
What do I want to say?
So beta is the ratio
of the lifetime
in the mRNA through the
lifetime of the protein.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I get
why we have to--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
No, I understand.
No, I understand you.
I'm getting to your question.
First, we have to
make since of this
because the next thing
is actually even weirder.
But I just want to
be clear that beta
is defined as the
lifetime of mRNA
over the lifetime
of the protein.
What's interesting
is, actually, there's
a typo or mistake in the
elements paper, actually.
So if you look at
figure 1B or so-- yeah,
so figure 1B, actually.
It says that beta is the protein
lifetime divided by the mRNA
lifetime.
So you can correct
that, if you like.
So beta's is the mRNA divided
by the lifetime of the protein.
OK, so I think
that we understand
why that term is there.
But the weird
thing is that we're
doing p minus m over here.
Right?
And it feels, somehow, that
that can't be possible.
You know, that it shouldn't
be beta times m over here
because it feels like
it's under determined.
Right?
OK.
So it's possible
I just screwed up.
But does anybody want to
defend my equation here?
How might it be possible that
this makes any sense that you
can just have the one beta
here that you pull out,
and it's just p
minus m over here?
AUDIENCE: I think it's an
assumption of the model where
they choose the lifetime
of the protein and the mRNA
to be similar.
PROFESSOR: Well no
because, actually, we
have this term beta, which
is the lifetime of mRNA
divided by lifetime of protein.
So we haven't assumed
anything about this beta.
It could be, in principle,
larger than one.
Smaller, actually.
So it's true that given typical
facts about life in the cell,
it's true that you expect
beta be much less than 1.
But we haven't made
any assumption.
Beta is just there.
It could be anything.
Right?
So yeah, it's possible we've
made some other assumption.
But what is going on.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it
the concentration
is scaled by the
amount of necessary--
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's
right because, remember,
you can only choose
one unit for time.
And we've already chosen that
to get this to be just minus m
here.
But you get to choose what's
the unit of concentration
for, both, mRNA and for protein.
Can somebody remind us what
the unit of concentration
is for protein?
AUDIENCE: The dissociation
constant of the protein
to the--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So it's this
dissociation constant.
And more generally, it's
the protein concentration,
which you get half
maximal repression.
And depending on
the detailed models,
it could be more complicated.
But in this phenomenological
realm, if p is equal to 1,
you get half repression.
And that's our definition
for what p equal to 1 means.
So we've rescaled out that k.
So what we've really
done is that there's
some unit for the
concentration of mRNA
that we were free to choose.
And it was chosen so that
you could just say p minus m.
But what that means is that it
requires a genius to figure out
what m equal to 1 means, right?
It doesn't quite
require a genius.
But what do you guys think
it's going to depend on?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's going to depend
on this ratio of lifetimes,
as well.
PROFESSOR: Yes, right.
So beta is going
to appear in there.
So I'll give you
a hint, there are
three things that determine it.
AUDIENCE: Transcription, or
the speed of transcription.
PROFESSOR: Translation, yes.
So the translation efficiency.
So each mRNA, it's going to
lead to some rate of protein
synthesis.
So yeah, the translation rate
or efficiency is going to enter.
There aren't that many
other things it could be.
But yeah, I mean,
this is tricky.
And it's OK if you can't
just figure it out here
because this, I think,
is pretty subtle.
It turns out it also
depends on that k parameter
because there's some sense
that-- m equal to 1-- what it's
saying is that that's
the amount of mRNA
that you need so that, if the
protein concentration where 1,
you would not get any change
in the protein concentration.
And given that now I
had to invoke p in there
and p is scaled by k,
so then k also ends up
being relevant for this mRNA.
So you can, if
you'd like, go ahead
and start with a original,
reasonable set of equations.
And then, get back to this.
But I think, once
again, this just
highlights that these
non-dimensional versions
of the equations are great.
But you have to be careful.
You don't know what means what.
All right?
Are there any questions
about what we've said so far?
OK.
Now what we've done is we have
now a protein concentration.
We have mRNA concentration.
And what I'm going to ask
for now is, for these sets
of equations, is it
mathematically possible
that they could,
maybe, oscillate?
Yes.
I mean, we're going to find
that the answer is that these
actually don't oscillate.
But have to actually
do the calculation
if you want to determine that.
You can't just say that
it's impossible based
on the same argument here.
And that's because, if
you think about this
in the case of there's
some mRNA concentration.
Some protein concentration.
What we want to know is do
things oscillate in this space.
And they could.
I mean, I could
certainly draw a curve.
It ends up not being true
for these particular sets
of equations.
But you can't a priori, kind
of, dismiss the possibility.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That's like a
differential equation.
But if you write down the
stochastic model of that,
would that--
PROFESSOR: OK, this is
a very good question.
So this is the differential
equation format of this
and that we're
assuming that there
are no stochastic fluctuations.
And indeed, there is a large
area of excitement, recently,
that is trying to understand
cases in which you can have,
so-called, noise
induced oscillations.
So you can have cases that the
deterministic equations do not
oscillate.
But if you do the full
stochastic treatment,
then that could oscillate.
In particular, if you do a
master equation type formalism.
And actually, I don't know,
for this particular equations.
Yeah, I don't know for this one.
But towards the end
of the semester,
we will be talking about
explicit models in which,
predator prey systems, in
which the differential equation
format doesn't oscillate.
But then, if you do the master
equation stochastic treatment,
then it does oscillate.
Yeah, so we will be talking
about this in other contexts.
But I don't know the
answer for this model.
All right, so let's
go and, maybe, try
to analyze this a little bit.
And this is useful to
do, partly because some
of the calculations are going
to be very similar to what we're
about to do next, which
is look at stability
analysis of a repressilator
kind of system.
All right.
So this thing here is some
function f of m and p.
And this guy here
is indeed, again,
some other function
g of m and p.
And we're going to be taking
derivatives of these functions
around the fixed point.
And maybe I will
also say there's
going to be some stable point.
We should just
calculate what it is.
I'm sorry I'm making
this go up and down.
Don't get dizzy.
So first of all, it's always
good to know whether there
are fixed points in
any sort of equations
that you ever look at.
So let's go ahead and see that.
First of all, is m equal
to 0, p equal to 0?
Is that a fixed
point in the system?
No.
Right?
So if m and p are 0, then
this is a fixed point.
But that one's
not because we get
expression of the mRNA in
the absence of the protein.
So the origin is
not a fixed point.
Now to figure out
the fixed points,
we just set these
things equal to 0.
So if m dot is equal
to 0, we have 0.
That's alpha 1 plus
p to the n minus m.
Again, 0 is this.
So what you can see is
that, at equilibrium, we
have a condition here
where m is equal to p.
So from this, we
get m equilibrium
is equal to p equilibrium.
So m equilibrium over here has
to be equal to p equilibrium,
we just said.
And that's equal
to this guy here.
It's alpha 1 plus p
equilibrium to the n.
All right.
And the condition
for this equilibrium
is then something
that looks like this.
Now this is maybe
not so intuitive.
But alpha is this non
dimensional version
of the strength of expression.
And what this is saying is
that, broadly, it's not obvious
how to solve this explicitly.
But as the strength
of expression goes up,
the equilibrium here-- and
I'm saying equilibrium.
And that's, maybe, a
little bit dangerous.
We might even want
to just call it--
it's a fixed point
in concentration,
so it doesn't have to be stable.
So if we don't want
to bias our thinking,
different people argue about
whether equilibrium should be
a stable or require a stable.
We could just call
it some p 0 if that
makes you less likely to
bias our thinking in terms
of whether this concentration
should be a stable or unstable
fixed point.
But for example, if we
have that, in these units,
if alpha is around
10, n might 2.
Then, this thing
gives us something.
It's in the range
of a couple or 2, 3.
I mean, you can calculate
what it should be.
2, 4, maybe even exactly 2.
Did that-- yeah.
All right, so yes.
I'm just giving an example.
If alpha were 10, then this
equilibrium concentration
or this fixed
point concentration
would be 2 if n were equal
to 2 to give you, kind
of, some sense of the numbers.
And this is 2 in units of that
binding affinity k, right.
Now the question is,
well, what does this mean?
Why did we do this?
Why do we care at all about the
properties of that fix point?
OK, so this might be some p 0.
And this is, again, m 0 is
equal to p 0 in these units.
So there's some fixed point
somewhere in the middle there.
Now it turns out that the
stability of that fixed point
is very important in determining
whether there are oscillations
or not.
Now the question
of the generality
or what can you say
that's universally
true about when you
get oscillations
and when you don't, this
is, in general, a very hard
mathematical
problem, particularly
in higher numbers of dimensions.
But for two dimensions,
there's a very nice statement
that you can make based on the
Poincare-Bendixson criterion.
I cannot remember
how to spell that.
I'm probably
mispronouncing it, as well.
So Poincare-Bendixson,
what they showed
is that if, in two
dimensions, you
can draw some box here such
that all of the trajectories
are, kind of, coming in.
And indeed, in this
case, they do come in
because the trajectories
aren't going to cross 0.
If you have some
mRNA, then you're
going to start making protein.
If you have just
protein, no mRNA,
you're going to start
making some mRNA.
And we know that trajectories
have to come in from out here
because if the
concentration of mRNA
and the concentration of
protein are very large then,
eventually, the
degradation is going
to start pulling things in.
So if you come out far
enough, eventually, you're
going to get
trajectories coming in.
So now we have
there is some domain
where all the trajectories
are going to come in.
Now you can imagine
that, somehow,
the stability of this thing is
very important because in two
dimensions here when you
have a differential equation,
trajectories cannot
cross each other.
So I'm not allowed
in any sort of space
like this to do something that
looks like this because this
would require that, at some
concentration of m and p,
I have different values
for m dot and p dot.
So it's similar to this argument
we made for one dimension.
But it's just generalized
to two dimensions.
So we're not allowed
to cross trajectories.
Well if you have a differential
equation in any dimensions,
that's true.
But the thing is
that this constraint
is a very strong constraint
in two dimensions.
Whereas, in three dimensions,
everything kind of goes out
the window because in
the three dimensions,
you have another axis here.
And then, these lines can do
all sorts of crazy things.
And that's actually, basically,
why you need three dimensions
in order to get chaos in
differential equations
because this thing about
the absence of crossing
is just such a strong
constraint in two dimensions.
Other questions about
what I'm saying right now?
I'm a little bit
worried that I'm--
All right, so the trajectories
are not allowed to cross.
And that's really saying
something very strong
because we know that,
here, trajectories are
going to come out of the axis.
And mRNA, we don't
know which direction
they're going to come.
But let's figure out,
if it were to oscillate,
would the trajectories be going
clockwise or counterclockwise?
And actually,
there's going to be
some sense of the
trajectories even
in the absence of oscillations.
But broadly, is there kind of
a counterclockwise or clockwise
kind of motion to
the trajectories?
Counterclockwise, right?
And that's because
mRNA leads to protein.
So things are going
to go like this.
And the question is is
it going to oscillate.
And in two dimensions,
actually-- Poincare-Bendixson--
what they say is
that, if there's just
one fixed point here,
then the question
of whether it oscillates
is the same as the question
of whether this is stable.
So if it's stable, then
there's no oscillations.
If it's unstable,
than there are.
We'll just say no
oscillations and oscillations.
And that's because if it's
a stable point and all
the trajectories are coming in,
then it just looks like this.
So it spirals, maybe, into
a state of coexistence.
Well it spirals to
this point of m and p.
Whereas, if it's unstable,
then those trajectories
are, somehow, being pushed out.
If it's unstable,
then the trajectories
are coming out of
that fixed point.
In which case, then
that's actually
precisely the situation in
which you get a limit cycle
oscillations.
So if the fixed
point were unstable,
it looks like this
because we have some box.
The trajectories are all
coming in, somehow, in here.
But if we have one
fixed point here
and the trajectories
are coming out,
that means we have something
that looks like this.
It kind of comes out.
And given that these
trajectories can't cross,
the question is, well,
what can happen in between?
And the answer
is, basically, you
have to get a limit
cycle oscillation.
There are these
strange situations
where you can get a path that
is an oscillation that's,
kind of, stable
from one direction
and unstable from another.
We're not going to
worry about that here.
But broadly, if this
thing is coming out,
then you end up,
in both directions,
converging to a stable
limit cycle oscillation.
So it's a unstable
fixed point, then
this is the exact situation,
which you get a limit cycle
oscillation.
OK.
So that means that,
what we really
want to do if we want to ask--
let's try to back up again.
We have this pair of
differential equations.
We want to know will this
negative auto regulatory loop
oscillate.
Now what I'm telling you
is that that question
for two dimensions is analogous
to the question of figuring out
whether this fixed
point is stable or not.
If it's stable, then we
don't get oscillations.
If it's unstable, then we do.
Any questions about this?
So let's see what is is.
On Tuesday, what we do is we
talked about stability analysis
for linear systems.
We got what I hope is
some intuition about that.
And of course, what
we need to do here
is try to understand how
to apply linear stability
analysis to this non-linear
pair of differential equations.
And to do that,
what we need to do
is we need to linearize
around that fixed point.
So what we have is we have
these two functions, f and g.
And what we want to know is
around that fixed point--
so we can define some m tilde,
which is m minus this m 0.
And some p tilde,
which is p minus p 0.
So when m tilde and
p tilde are around 0,
that's telling us that we're
close to that fixed point.
And we want to know, if we just
go a little away from the fixed
point, do we get pushed
away or do we come back
to where we started?
Well we know that m tilde dot,
which is actually equal to m
dot, as well because m
0 and p 0 are the same.
p tilde dot.
We can linearize by taking
derivatives around the fixed
points.
And in particular,
what we want to do
is we want to take the
derivative of f with respect
to m.
Evaluate at the fixed point.
That derivative is,
indeed, just minus 1.
So in general, in these
situations, what we have is
we have derivatives
m, m dot p dot,
and we have partial of this
first function f with respect
to m.
Partial of g.
Oh, no.
So this is still f.
Respect to p.
Down here is derivative
g with respect to m.
Derivative g with respect to p.
And this is all evaluated
around the fixed point m 0 p 0.
So we want to take
these derivatives
and evaluate at the fixed point.
And if we do that,
we get minus 1 here,
derivative m with respect
to m times m tilde.
This other guy, when
you take the derivative,
you get a minus sign
with respect to p.
So we get a minus sign because
this is in the denominator.
And then, we have to
take derivative inside.
So we get n alpha p
0 to the n minus 1.
And down, we get a
1 plus p 0 squared.
So we took the derivative of
this term with respect to p.
And we evaluated at
the fixed point p 0.
Did I do that right?
But we still have
to add a p tilde
because this is
saying how sensitive
is the function to
changes in where
you are times how far you've
gone away from the fixed point.
And then, again, over here,
we take the derivatives
down below.
So derivative g
with respect to m.
That gives us a beta m tilde.
And then, we have a
minus beta p tilde.
All right, so this
is just an example
of linearizing those equations
around that fixed point.
So ultimately, what we
care about is really
this matrix that's
specifying deviations
around the equilibrium.
Right?
So it's useful to just write it
in matrix format because we get
rid of some of the M's and P's.
Indeed, so this matrix that we
either call A or the Jacobean
depending on-- so what
we have is a minus 1.
And we're going
to call this thing
x because it's going to pop up
a lot is this minus n alpha p 0.
So it's an x beta
and minus beta.
And then, we have
our simple rules
for determining whether this
thing is going to be stable
or not.
It depends on the trace.
And it depends on
the determinant.
So the trace should be negative.
And is this trace negative?
Yes.
Yes because beta-- does anybody
remember what beta was again.
AUDIENCE: Ratio of lifetimes.
PROFESSOR: Ratio of lifetimes.
Lifetimes are positive.
So beta is positive.
All right, so the trace is
equal to minus 1 minus beta.
This is, indeed, less than 0.
So this is consistent
for stability.
Does prove that it's stable?
No.
But we also need to know
about the determinant of a,
which is going to be
beta, this times this,
minus this times this.
So that's minus.
And this is a beta
times what x was.
So this gives us--
we can write this
all down just so that it's clear
that it has to be positive.
So beta is positive.
Positive, positive,
positive, positive, positive.
Everything's positive.
So this thing has to
be greater than 0.
So what does this mean about
the stability of Ethics Point?
Stable.
Fixed point stable.
And what does that mean
about oscillations?
It means there are
no oscillations.
Fixed point stable.
Therefore, no oscillations.
So what this is saying is that
the original, kind of simple,
equation we wrote down for
negative auto regulation,
that thing was not allowed
to oscillate mathematically.
But that doesn't mean that, if
you explicitly model the mRNA,
it could go either way.
But still, that's insufficient
to generate oscillations.
However, maybe if you
included more steps,
maybe it would oscillate.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So just to double
check-- when you said,
no oscillations, you
mean stable oscillations?
PROFESSOR: That's right, sorry.
When I mean no oscillations,
what I mean are indeed,
no limit cycle oscillations.
AUDIENCE: This is
like a dampened--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, so we, actually,
have not solved
exactly what it looks like.
And I've drawn this is a
pretty oscillatory thing.
But it might just look
like this, depending
on the parameters and so forth.
And indeed, we haven't
even proven that this thing
has complex eigenvalues.
But certainly, there are no
limit cycle oscillations.
And I'd say it's really limit
cycle oscillations that people
find most exciting as because
limit cycle oscillations have
a characteristic amplitude.
So it doesn't matter
where you start.
The oscillations go
to some amplitude.
And they have a
characteristic period, again,
independent of your
starting condition.
So a limit cycle
oscillation has a feeling
similar to a stable
fixed point in the since
that it doesn't matter
where you start.
You always end up there.
So they're the ones
that are really
what you would
call mathematically
nice oscillations.
And when I say this,
I'm, in particular,
comparing them to
neutrally stable orbits.
So there are cases in
which, in two variables,
you have a fixed point here.
And at least in the case
of linear stability,
if you have purely
imaginary eigenvalues,
what that means is that
you have orbits that
go around your fixed point.
And we'll see some cases
that look like this later on.
And this is, indeed, the
nature of the oscillations
in the Lotka-Volterra model
for predator prey oscillations.
They're not actually
limit cycle oscillations.
They're of this kind that are
considered less interesting
because they're less robust.
Small changes in the model
can cause these things
to either go away, to turn into
this kind of stable spiral,
or to turn into limit
cycle oscillations.
So we'll talk about this
more in a couple months.
These are neutrally
stable orbits.
OK, but what I
wanted to highlight,
though, is that just because
the original, simple, protein
only model didn't oscillate
and this protein mRNA together
doesn't oscillate does
not mean that it's
impossible to get oscillations
using negative auto
regulation, either
experimentally
or computationally.
And the question
is, what might you
need to do to get oscillations?
AUDIENCE: So in the paper
they talk about leakage
in the negative--
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So in the paper, they
talk about various things,
including things
such as leakage.
It terms out that
leakage in an expression
only inhibits
oscillations though.
So in some sense, if you're
trying to get oscillations,
leakage is a problem, actually.
And that's why they use
this especially tight-- well
we're going to talk about
that in a few minutes.
They use an especially tight
version of these promoters
to have low rates of
leakage in a synthesis.
But what might you need in
order to get oscillations
in negative autoregulation?
Did you have-- have delay.
Yes indeed.
And that's something that they
mentioned in the Elowitz paper
is if you add explicit delay.
So for example, if instead of
having the repression depend
on--OK, I already
erased everything.
But instead of having
the protein, for example,
being a function of the
mRNA now, maybe if you said,
oh, it's a function of
the mRNA five minutes ago.
And that's just because maybe it
takes time to make the protein.
Or it takes time
for this or that.
You could introduce an
explicit delay like that.
Or you could even,
instead, have a model
where you just have more steps.
So what you do is you
say, oh, well yeah, sure.
What happens is that,
first, the mRNA is made.
But then, after
the mRNA is made,
then you have to make
the peptide chain.
Then, the that peptide
chain has to fold.
And then, maybe, those
proteins have to multimerize.
Indeed, if you right
down such a model
then, for some
reasonable parameters,
you can get oscillations just
with negative auto regulation.
And indeed, I would say
that over the last 10 years,
probably, the reigning
king of oscillations
in the field of system
synthetic biology
is Jeff Hasty at San Diego.
And he's written a whole train
of beautiful papers exploring
how you can make these
oscillators in simple G
network.
So he's been
focusing in E. coli.
There's also been great
work in higher organisms
in this regard.
But let's say, Hasty's
work stands out
in terms of really being
able to take these models
and then implement them
in cells and, kind of,
going back and forth.
And he's shown that you can
generate oscillations just
using negative auto
regulation if you
have enough delays in that
negative feedback loop.
Are there any questions
about where we are right now?
I know that we're
supposed to be talking
about the repressilator.
But we first have to make sure
we understand the negative auto
regulation.
So everything that we've said,
so far, in terms of the models
was all known.
But what Michael wanted to do
is ask whether he could really
construct an oscillator.
And he did this using these
three mutual reppressors.
We'll say x, y,
and z just for now.
x represses y, represses
z, represses x.
And has a nice
model of this system
that helped him guide the
design of his circuits.
So experiments--
as most of us who
have done them know--
experiments are hard.
So if you can do
a week of thinking
before you do a year of
experimental biology,
then you should do that.
And what were the
lessons that he
learned from the modeling
that guided his construction
of this circuit?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Lifetime of mRNA.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you want to have
similar lifetime
of the mRNA and the protein.
And this is, somehow,
similar to this idea
that you need more delay
elements because if you
have very different lifetimes,
then the more rapid process,
somehow, doesn't count.
It's very hard to increase the
lifetime of the mRNA that much
in bacteria.
So instead, what he
did is he decreased
the lifetime of the proteins
of the transcription factors.
In this case, x, y, and z.
And you mentioned the other
thing that he maybe did.
AUDIENCE: He
introduced the leakage,
but he didn't
mention that that was
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So I guess, he knew that leakage
was going to be a problem.
I.e, that you want
tight repression.
So he used these
synthetic promoters
that both had high
level of expression when
on but then very low
level of expression
when being repressed.
He made this thing.
And in particular, he
looked at it in a test tube.
He was able to use, in this
case, IPDG to synchronize them.
And he looked at the
fluorescence in the test tube.
So the fluorescence is reporting
on one of the proteins.
We can call it x if we'd like.
But fluorescence is kind
of telling about the state.
And if it starts out, say,
here, he saw a single cycle.
Damped oscillations, maybe.
So the question is,
why did this happen?
So why is it that,
in the test tube,
he didn't see something
that looked very nice?
Oscillations.
Noise.
And in particular,
what kind of noise?
Or what's going on?
Desynchronization, exactly.
So the idea is that,
even if you start out
with them all synchronized--
you give it IPDG pulls,
and they're synchronized
in some way--
it may be that, at the
beginning, all of them
are oscillating in
phase with each other.
But over time, random
noise, phase drift,
and the different oscillators
leads to some of them
come down and come back up.
And then, others are slower.
You start averaging all
these things together.
And it leads to damped
oscillations at the test tube
level within the bulk.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what do you
mean in the test tube?
Like, you just take all
these components and put it--
PROFESSOR: Sorry, when I
say test tube, what I mean
is that you have all the cells.
So they still are intact cells.
But it's just many cells.
So then, the signal that
you get the fluorescence
is some average over
all or sum overall.
The fluorescence you get
from all those cells.
So there's a sense
that this is really
what you expect given
the fact that they're
going to desynchronize.
Of course, the better the
oscillator in the sense
that the lower the
phase drift, then maybe
you can see a slower rate of
this kind of desynchronization.
But this is really what
you, kind of, expect.
All right.
So that's what, maybe,
led him to go and look
at the single cell
level where he put down
single cells on this
agar pad and just
imaged as the cells
oscillated and divided.
Now there are a
few features that
are important to
note from the data.
The first is that
they do oscillate.
That's a big deal
because this was, indeed,
the first demonstration
of being able to put
these random components
together like that
and generate oscillation.
But they didn't
oscillate very well.
So they said, oh, maybe 40%
of the cells oscillated.
And I have no idea what the
rest of the cells were doing.
But also, even the cells
that were oscillating, there
was a fair amount of
noise to the oscillation.
And the latter
half of this paper
has a fair amount of discussion
of why that might be.
And they allude to the ideas
that had been bouncing around
and from the theoretical
computational side
demonstrating that it may
be that the low numbers
of proteins, genes involved
here could introduce
stochastic noise into the
system and, thus, lead
to this kind of phase drift that
was observed experimentally.
I think that this
basic observation
that Michael had that
he got oscillations,
but they were noisy.
That is probably
what led him to start
thinking more and more about
the role of noise in G networks
and so forth and led,
later, to another hugely
influential paper that is
not going to be a required
reading in this
class but is listed
under the optional reading,
if you're interested.
But we'll really get into this
question of noise more a couple
weeks from now.
Were there any other questions
about the experimental side
of this paper?
I wanted to analyze maybe a
little bit of simple model
of the repressilator.
So the model that
they used to help
them design this experiment
involved all three proteins,
all three mRNAs.
And what that means is that,
when you go and you do a model,
you're going to end up
with a six by six matrix.
And I don't have boards
that are big enough.
So what I'm going
to do instead is
I'm going to analyze just
the protein only version
model of the repressilator.
All right.
So what we have here
is three proteins.
p1 2 3 p1 dot.
And we have degradation
of this protein.
And we're going to analyze
the symmetric version, just
like what Michael did.
So that means we're assuming
that all the proteins are
equivalent.
I'm sure that's not true because
these are different promoters
and different everything.
But this gives us the intuition.
So it's minus p1.
And this is protein 1 is
repressed by trajectory protein
3.
Protein 2 is going to be
repressed by protein 1.
And then protein 3 is going
to be repressed by protein 2.
So this is what you would
call the protein only model
of the repressilator.
Now just as before,
the fixed points
are when the pi
dots are equal to 0.
And we get the same
equation that we, basically,
had before where the
equilibrium or the fixed point,
again, is going to be given by
something that looks like this.
So it's the same requirement
that we had before.
Now the question is, how
can we get the stability
of that internal fixed point?
It's worth mentioning here that
now we have three proteins.
So the trajectories are in
this three dimensional space.
So from a mathematical
standpoint,
determining the stability of
that internal fixed point is
actually not sufficient to
tell you that there has to be
oscillations or there cannot
be oscillations because these
trajectories are, in principal,
allowed to do all sorts
of crazy things in
three dimensions.
But it turns out
that it still ends up
being true here that when this
internal fixed point is stable,
you don't get oscillations.
And when it's unstable, you do.
But that, sort of,
didn't have to be
true from a
mathematical standpoint.
All right.
Now since this is now going
to be a 3 by 3 matrix,
we're going to have to
calculate those eigenvalues.
Now how many eigenvalues
are there going to be?
Three?
OK.
So this thing I've written
in the form of a matrix
to help us out a little bit.
But in particular, we're
going to get the same thing
that we had before,
which is the p1 tilde.
So these are deviations,
again, from the fixed point.
And we got this matrix that's
going to look like this.
Minus 1, again, 0.
It's the same x that we had
before conveniently still
on the board.
So this is just after we
take these derivatives.
And then, we have p1 tilde,
p2 tilde, and p3 tilde.
Now what we need to know
is, for this Jacobian,
what are going to
be the eigenvalues?
For this thing to be
stable, it requires what?
What's the requirement for
stability of that fixed point?
That p0?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Right.
For two dimensions, this trace
and determinant condition
works.
It's important to say that that
only works for two dimensions,
actually, the rule about
traces and determinants.
So be careful.
So what's the more
general statement?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Negative eigenvalues.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So in order for that
fixed point to be stable,
it requires that
all the eigenvalues
have real parts less than 0.
So in order to determine the
stability of the fixed point,
we need to ask what are the
eigenvalues of this matrix.
And to get the
eigenvalues, what we do
is we calculate this
characteristic equation,
this thing that we learned about
in linear algebra and so forth.
What we do is we take-- all
right, this is the matrix A,
we'll say.
This is matrix A. And
what we want to do
is we want to ask
whether the determinant
of the matrix A minus some
eigenvalue times the identity
matrix.
We want this thing
to be equal to 0.
So this is how we determine
what the eigenvalues are.
And this is not as bad as it
could be for general three
by three matrices because a
lot of these things are 0.
So this thing is just
this is the determinant
of the following matrix.
So we have minus
1 minus lambda 0.
This thing x that's,
in principle, bad.
Minus 1 minus lambda 0.
Getting 0 x minus
1 minus lambda.
Now to take the
determinant three by three
matrix, remember, you can
say, well, this determinant
is going to be equal
to-- we have this term.
So this is a minus 1 plus a
lambda times the determinant
of this matrix.
And then, we just
have that's this.
The product of these minus
the product of these.
So this just gives
us this thing again.
So this is actually just
minus 1 plus lambda cubed.
Next term, this is 0.
That's great.
We don't need to
worry about that.
The next one, we get plus.
We have an x.
Determining here, we
get, again, x squared.
So this is just an x cubed.
We want the same equal to 0.
So we actually get a
very simple requirement
for the eigenvalues,
which is that 1
plus the eigenvalues cubed is
equal to this thing x cubed.
Now be careful
because, remember,
x is actually a negative number.
So watch out.
So I think that the best
way to get a sense of what
this thing is is to plot it.
Of course, it's a
little bit tempting
here to just say,
all right, well,
can we just say that 1
plus lambda is equal to x?
No.
So what's the matter with that?
I mean, it's, sort of,
true, maybe, possibly.
Right.
So the problem
here is that we're
supposed to be getting
three different eigenvalues.
Or at lease, it's
possible to get
three different eigenvalues.
So this is really specifying
the solution for 1
plus lambda on
the complex plane.
So the solution
for 1 plus lambda
we can get by
thinking about this
is the real part
of 1 plus lambda.
And this is the imaginary
part of 1 plus lambda.
And we know that one solution
is going to be out here at x.
This distance here is
the magnitude of x.
Now the others,
however, are going
to be around the complex plane
similar distances where we get
something that looks like this.
So these are, like,
30, 60, 90 triangle.
So this is 30 degrees
here because what
you see is that, for each of
these three solutions for 1
plus lambda, if you cube
them, you end up with x cubed.
So this guy, you square it.
Cube.
You end up back here.
This one, if you cube
it, you start out here,
squared, and then cubed
comes back out here.
Same thing and this
goes around somehow.
All right, so there
are three solutions
to this 1 plus lambda.
And there are these points here.
Now, of course, it's
not 1 plus lambda
that we actually
wanted to know about.
It was lambda.
But if we know what
1 plus lambda is,
then we can get what lambda is.
What do we have to do?
Right, we have to
slide it to the left.
So this is the real axis.
This is the imaginary axis.
1.
So we have to move
everything over 1.
Now remember, the
requirement for stability
was that all of the
eigenvalues have
real parts that were negative.
That means the requirement for
stability of that fixed point
is that all three of
these fixed points
are in the left
half of the plane.
So what you can see is
that, in this problem,
the whole question of
stability and whether we
get oscillations boils down
to how big this thing is.
What's this distance?
If this distance is more
than 1, then we subtract 1,
we don't get it into the
left part of the plane.
OK, I can't remember
which case I just gave.
But yeah, we need to know
whether this thing is
larger or smaller than 1.
And that has to do with
the magnitude of x.
So if the magnitude
of x-- do you
guys remember your geometry
for a 30, 60, 90 triangle?
All right, so if the
magnitude of x-- and this
is indeed the magnitude of x.
This short edge on a 30, 60, 90
is half the long edge, right?
So what we can say is that
this fixed point stable, state
fixed point, is if and only
if the magnitude of x is what?
Lesson two.
OK.
That's nice.
And if we want, we could plug
in-- just to ride this out.
This is n alpha p 0 n minus 1.
So it's useful, once you
get to something like this,
to try to just ask, for
various kind of values,
how does this play out?
What does the
requirement end up being?
And a useful limit is
to think about what
happens in the limit of
very strong expression?
So strong expression
corresponds to what?
AUDIENCE: Big alpha?
PROFESSOR: Big alpha.
Yes, perfect.
And it turns out, big
alpha is a little bit-- OK,
and remember we have to
remember what p0 was.
p0 was this p0 times 1 plus p0.
All right, so this
is the requirement.
And actually, if you
play with these equations
just a little bit,
what you'll find
is that, if alpha is
much larger than 1,
then this requirement
is that n is less than 2
or less than around 2.
This is saying,
on the flip side,
the fixed point is stable if
you don't have very strong
cooperativity and repression.
And the flip side is, if you
have strong cooperativity
of repression, then you
can get oscillations
because this interior fixed
point becomes unstable.
So this is also saying that
n greater than around 2
leads to oscillations.
And this maybe
makes sense because,
when you have strong
productivity in the repression
there, what that's
telling you is that it's
a switch like response.
And in that regime,
it maybe becomes more
like a simple Boolean
kind of network
where, if you just write
down the ones and zeroes,
you can convince yourself that
this thing maybe, in principle,
could oscillate.
Now if you look at the
Elowitz repressilator paper,
you'll see that he gives
some expression for what
this thing should be like.
And it looks vaguely similar.
Of course, there he's
including the mRNAs, as well.
But if you think that this
was painful to do in class,
then including the
mRNAs is more painful.
Are there any questions
about this idea?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in the paper, did
they also only do the stability
analysis to determine the--
PROFESSOR: I think they
did simulations, as well.
So the nature of simulations is
that you can convince yourself
that their exist places that do
oscillate or don't oscillate.
Although, you'll notice
that they have a very,
kind of, enigmatic
sentence in here,
which is that it is
possible that, in addition
to simple oscillations, this
and more realistic models
may exhibit other complex
types of dynamic behavior.
And this is just
a way of saying,
well, you know, I don't know.
Maybe someday
because once you talk
about six dimensional
system, you never
know if you've explored
all of the parameter space.
I mean, even for
fixed parameters,
you don't know if you started
at all the right locations.
You can kind develop
some sense that, oh,
this thing seems to oscillate
or seems to not oscillate.
And it does correspond
to these conditions.
But you don't know.
I mean, it could be
that, in some regions,
you get chaos or other things.
Right?
So it's funny because I've
read this paper many times.
But it was only last night
when I was re-reading it
that I kind of thought
about that sense
like, yeah, I'm not sure either
what this model could possibly
do.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In this
linear analysis
the three x's are the same.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Because
they're non-dimensional?
PROFESSOR: All right.
So the reason that the
three X's are the same
is because we've
assumed that this really
is the symmetric version
of the repressilator
because we're assuming
that all of the alphas, all
the ends, all the
K's, everything's
the same across
all three of them.
So given that
symmetry, then you're
always going to end up with
a symmetric version of this.
So I think if it were
asymmetric and then you
made the non-dimensional
versions of things,
I think you still won't end
up getting the same X's just
because, if it's asymmetric,
then and something has
to be asymmetric.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so
large alpha leads to--
PROFESSOR: Yes, OK.
We can go ahead and do this.
So for large alpha,
this fixed point
is going to be-- p0 is going
to be much larger than 1.
So this is about
p0 to the n plus 1.
We can neglect the
1 for large alpha.
And then and then
what we can say
is that, over here, for
example, if we multiply
both sides by-- p0 squared, p0
squared, so multiply it by one.
Then this down here is
definitely alpha squared.
And then, up here,
what we have is
p0 to the n plus 1, which
we decided was around
alpha for a strong alpha.
So that gives us alpha times
alpha divided by alpha squared.
So this actually all goes
away for large alpha.
So then, you're just
left with n less than 2.
Did that--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Where did that top right
equation come from?
PROFESSOR: OK, so this
equation here is this
is the solution for where
that fixed point is.
So in this space of the p0's,
if you set the equations
for p1, p2, p3, if you
set that equal to 0,
this is the expression always
for a large alpha, small.
So this is a need be
location of that fixed point.
And it's just, as
alpha is large,
then we get that
p0 to the n plus 1
is approximately equal to alpha.
And this is for alpha
much greater than 1.
And in that case, all of
these things just go away.
And you're just left
with n less than 2.
So for example, as alpha
goes down in magnitude,
then you end up getting a
requirement that oscillations
require a larger n.
We'll give you practice on this.
All right, so I think I wrote
another-- if I can find my--
you can ask for
alpha equal to 2.
What n required
for oscillations.
I'll let you start
playing with that.
And I will make sure
that I've given you
the right alpha to use.
So in this case,
what we're asking is,
instead of having really strong
maximal expression, if instead
expression is just not quite
as strong, then what we'll find
is that you actually
need to have
a more cooperative repression
in order to get oscillations.
And that's just because,
if alpha is equal to 2,
then we can, kind of, figure
out what p0 is equal to.
1.
Right.
Great.
So the fixed point is at one.
That's great because this
we can then figure out.
Right?
So this is 1 plus 1 square.
That's a four.
1.
2.
So this tells us
that, in this case,
we need to have very
cooperative repression.
We have to have an n
greater than around 4
in order to get oscillations
in this protein only model.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It is kind
of strange that even
for a really big alpha you
still need n greater than sum.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right, right.
So this is an
interesting question
that you might think that
for a very large expression
that you wouldn't need to have
cooperative repression at all.
Right?
And I can't say that I have any
wonderful intuition about this
because it, somehow,
has to do with just
the slopes of those curves
around that fixed point.
And it's in three dimensions.
But I think that this
highlights that it's
a priori if you
go and say, oh, I
want to construct
this repressilator,
it's maybe not even obvious that
you want it to be more or less.
I mean, you might not
even think about this idea
of cooperative repression.
You might be tempted to
think that any chain of three
proteins repressing each
other just, kind of,
has to oscillate.
I mean, there's a
little bit of a sense.
And that's the logic that
you get at if you just do
0's and 1's.
If you say, oh, here's x.
Here's y.
Here's z.
And they're
repressing each other.
Right?
And you say, oh, OK, well if
I start out at, say, 0 1 0
and you say, OK,
that's all fine.
But OK, so this is repressing.
And it's OK, but this guy
wasn't repressing this one.
So now we get a 1, 1, 0, maybe.
Then you say, oh, OK.
Well now this guy starts
repressing this one.
So now it gives us a 1 0 0.
And what you see is that, over
these two steps, the on protein
has shifted.
And indeed, that's
going to continue
going all the way around.
So from this Boolean
logic kind of perspective,
you might think that any
three proteins mutually
repressing each other
just has to oscillate.
And it's only by looking
at things a little bit
more carefully that
you say, oh, well, we
have to actually worry
about this that you really
have to think about you want
to choose some transcription
factors that are multimerizing
and cooperatively repressing
the next protein just to have
some reasonable shot at having
this thing actually oscillate.
AUDIENCE: So in this, we
might still be able-- I mean,
oscillations like this
might still [INAUDIBLE]
but just not like,
maybe, oscillations
around some stable fix
point or something.
Like, they're just not
limit cycle oscillations.
Do you think that
in a [INAUDIBLE]
there would probably still
be some kind of oscillations
somewhere.
Just not this beautiful
limit cycle kind.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
my understanding
is that in, for example,
this protein only model
of the repressilator
that if you do not
have cooperative repression,
then it really just
goes to that stable fixed point.
Of course, you have
to worry about maybe
these noise-induced
oscillation ideas.
But at least within the
realm of the deterministic,
differential equations,
then the system
just goes to that internal fixed
point that's specified by this.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can we think like
that the cooperation, sort of,
introduced delay?
PROFESSOR: That's an
interesting question.
Whether cooperativity, maybe,
is introducing a delay.
And that's because, after
the proteins are made,
maybe it takes some extra
time to dimer and so forth.
So that statement may be true.
But it's not relevant.
OK?
And I think this
is very important.
This model has certainly
not taken that into account.
So the mechanism that's here
is not what you're saying.
But it may be true that,
for any experimental system,
such delay from dimerization
is relevant and helps
you get oscillations.
Right?
But at least within the
realm of this model,
we have very much not included
any sort of delay associated
with dimerization or anything.
So that is very much
not the explanation
for why dimerization leads
to oscillations here.
And I think this
is a wider point
that it's very important
always to keep track
of which effects you've
included in any given analysis
and which ones are not.
And it's very, very common.
There are many
things that are true.
But they may not actually be
relevant for the discussion
at hand.
And I think, in
those situations,
it's easy to get mixed up
because it still is true,
even if it's not what's
driving the effect that is
being, in this case, analyzed.
We're out of time.
So we should quit.
On Tuesday, we'll start by
wrapping up the oscillation
discussion by talking about
other oscillator designs that
allow for robustness
and tunability.
OK?